hey guys this is dense the founder fake
Carol and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and we just want to kind of just chat
about our comic-con 2013 experience you
know I'm comic-con is is my favorite
time of the year like it for me it's
like my birthday Christmas New Year's
Eve all wrapped into one side I love
going I mean usually I go you know I
have to work you know I had to shoot a
lot of stuff at some of you guys know I
work for AMC theater so shooting a lot
of the press line stuff so I missed a
lot of Hall H star but even still like
just the energy that Comic Con has all
the fans that going to the floor seeing
all the cool displays um you know
talking to people seeing people we
haven't seen in a while it's kind of
like I was described as kind of like a
high school reunion yeah step 4 it's
people i actually want to say exactly
exactly it's people i actually like so
yeah how was your comic-con it was great
um may not just like other kind of
experience yes was doing a lot working
with AMC theaters or a lot of the big
stuff marble panels a sony like all that
kind of stuff I was doing some of the
smaller things like it was fun I got to
do this new a flashpoint paradox movie
that's coming out from Warner Brothers
entertainment DC animation was fun I got
talked about my favorite voice you know
directors Andrea Romano who does all
this stuff for all the Justice League
cartoons from when we were kids and
legend of korra and avatar last
airbender cartoon series so that was
awesome I got to do the batman arkham
origins i have an articled there and
think here right now I'm gonna check
that out I interviewed a couple of voice
actors from that which was great and
it's fun like I mean I'm more doing
press stuff but even with the people we
were meeting even like we're in line
waiting to get in a pen i was i went to
go see James Spader's new show on Fox I
forgot what's even called nothing
informant I don't know some James Beard
got no the blacklist blacklist and he
just hitting the lines like an hour me
see Emmys yeah and it was good it was
good that the panel was good and not
just that just waiting in line I like
meeting people yeah oh you're always
gonna talk to somebody in line right on
is like you don't have to mmm like you
can talk to anyway I talk to people on
that bus I'd like to be right line it's
just like it's a happy play always cause
it's the happiest place on earth
everybody ones like these a screw
Disneyland
comic con happiest place on earth
everyone wants to be there everyone's
passionate about stuff sure there's a
few chroma jeans wearing their crowds on
the whole but in general you should be
just you should be thankful that you're
there you know why else are you there
then there's a lot of people that want
to go and people aren't pressed like us
and professionals no trying to get
tickets waiting out you know whatever
that waiting room with like 10,000
people I get so hard to get tickets and
it is yeah it's fun I mean you get to
see you don't you don't have to go to
haul age to get it i mean i was at the
75th anniversary of superman and that
was awesome the cool panel in room 6a
which is like maybe the fourth or fifth
biggest room not that big i didn't easy
Henry Cavill shows up kind of crashes
like David Goyer showed up and then some
other you know people from Tim Daly who
did the from was young Jagger wings they
did the boy the boy said supermen
animated series he was there it's just
fun you don't have to go to the biggest
panels to have a good time there's small
stuff to you i wish i was in college
though yeah I wish I could've seen that
low key as I've watched that about three
times all right that low key things
cooled every presentation did was good
yeah so what were some highlights for
you so how this definitely a couple of
panels like the 75th anniversary
Superman was cool um just walk can I
just say walking around san diego i was
around i'm a supernatural fan i was
walking around oh you know the gaslamp
district to trying to find a restaurant
or something and castiel guy who plays
Castiel from Supernatural walks by amis
by himself i just kind of pat him on the
shoulders and hey i'm a huge fan and
most of the slippers you meet there that
are walking on the aren't escorted by
security are really nice and he was like
oh man thank you thank you for saying hi
like he doesn't know who i am some
random guy inside a super like if you
can actually almost not don't be creepy
you can reach out and sometimes i don't
be breathing don't know assault but
reach out and touch reach out and touch
someone yeah you get your favorite
celebrities from some of these shows
that aren't there not a list actors but
you know they're people that you care
about your passionate about that's
that's what logo con you never know
you're gonna see ya like I I did two of
my highlights uh i photobomb the picture
that simon pegg was in her head at the
World's End IGN party and who's taking a
picture with I think one of my friends
friends and I photobombed it and then to
I got a high five from Sam jacks
yeah he was going up the escalator and
me and some of the other guys were
coming down and you know we got some
high five you know that was cool right
it wasn't creepy rising whatever is just
like cool you know I saw the cast of the
following I saw like all different types
of people you know and it's just a lot
of fun yeah I mean second year in a row
I see the whole cast of The Walking Dead
walk by me I mean it's just little
things it's just it's cool it can be I
mean there's something there for
everyone booth displays like this full
walking dead is awesome it was like
school that prison had zombies groan
pictures with right you wait in line you
can go inside and they had the
governor's yeah heads the heads jars of
heads in there and you could take
picture there and and i would say video
game fans you know it was III super hard
against that's just industry and press
so if you can't get to e3 xbox one was
there ps4 was there got to go over and
check out the booth you and i did an
elastic and aesthetic see the system
little the graphics graphics look great
you know got a plan he had the play I me
I mean it's like it's everything it's
should I mean it should be called pop
culture calm yes not I mean coming down
that Club books is if you weren't like
some breathing room on the floor go to
the comic book section yeah I can I than
I feel it's kind of diminishing it's
more pop culture now yeah definitely the
movies and television definitely super
super packed up I you know I saw some
displays for Pacific Rim yeah oh great
new new action figures from I think it's
Sideshow Collectibles ok cool toys like
he was like you know Kai geo that it
looked looked awesome yeah it's just so
cool and then you know if you are
confounded a lot of the convo writers
and artists are there and very
accessible all right you go up to the
talk to them and you know get a sketch
yeah if you fork out a little money get
a sketch you know yeah its signing
autographs yeah like that yeah
everybody's relay back I mean it yeah
it's it's ritas kind of high stress if
you think about it is there's so many
people but like at the same time
everybody wants to be there so I really
meet any grumpy people yeah there's a
few here and there but in general most
people are very happy yeah and just
having a good time right now I comicon
yeah I mean it's very tiring y al who's
exhausted the fifth day yeah I I could
do twice a year
yeah it is why did he had twice a year I
could do it but another thing is those
other conferences like I've been we've
been to but you and I both been to
wondercon that they're nice but like the
energies just not there was a wunderkind
a couple he like gives us two years ago
not lashing with you before last the
Prometheus panel Ridley Scott comes out
and they cheered but like it was like
kind of quiet I'm like I'm like no like
this is Ridley Scott like the future of
the Alien franchise at Hall H that will
just go nah wondercon is kinda like you
know woo it's just the comic-con like
when Loki watch just watch that Loki
video online find it um people or the
Batman vs Superman announcement right
people is David win nuts the stream com
that's why I like Hall H you know cuz
the energy there's just like a rock on
yeah that's a rock concert yeah so so
that's maybe sometimes it's worth
waiting into a lot two in the morning to
get in all age yeah so if you guys
haven't been you definitely should try
and make it out there I I always go for
all all days all four days and yes it's
just a blast so yeah let us know uh if
you guys went in what your experience
was like what was your favorite moment
was a favorite panel that you went to do
you see any cool like people from shows
that you watch movies you watch or
anything like that or you know maybe
some cool parties you went to you can
post your comments on the website or on
our YouTube video that's below here
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
think Harold pro and you also find us on
Twitter i'm at griffin de i am at think
hero and we also have a Facebook page
that facebook.com slash stinky row fans
you